Excitement has been building
up ahead of Apple's latest
event that kicked off
just a short while ago
and for good reason to the company
just unveiled its most ambitious product
in years.
Its wait for it,
a headset
that lets people experience both virtual
and augmented reality
does that by overlaying virtual images
and apps on the real world.
I want to bring in John Sarlin,
the host of Nightcap over
at CNN Business. And.
And John, I was hearing
they've just announced that
in the last
few minutes,
the most significant product
launch in nearly a decade.
So what do you make of this new product,
this mixed reality headset?
That's right.
Some moments ago,
Apple CEO
Tim Cook announcing
Vision Pro, the new product from Apple.
This is their biggest new hardware
since the Apple Watch.
And it's Apple's first foray
into air augmented reality.
So, you know,
virtual reality a screen in your face.
This is something that you see through
like aluminum ski goggles on your head
that melds the real world
with the virtual world.
Okay,
so how is this different,
John, than playing
video, a virtual reality video game?
Just bring us, you know,
give us the vision here from Tim
Cook in terms of the future
of how we could be using this,
because this this thing looks like
it will be perfect for skiing.
Right.
So, I mean, up to this
point, VR has kind of been
a niche product. You mentioned gaming.
That's really been
one of the big use cases.
But Apple is going for the mainstream
consumer here.
They're going for fitness,
they're going for face time,
they're going through productivity
and they're looking to expand the pool
from beyond that just niche gaming space.
Yes, but the price tag, John, I might be
I mean, it leaves a lot to be desired.
What I'd read
and maybe you heard it there,
I had something like $3,000
How much will this be a tough sell,
you think, for consumers here?
Right.
So they still haven't
announced the price,
but that is the big question, right?
Rumors are that
it should be around $3,000.
That's a lot of money.
The closest competition here is
Oculus is met as Oculus headset
that cost a few hundred dollars.
So Apple is taking a big risk here
with this product
where their demand isn't really proven.
But also going from on a price point
that is way beyond
what's currently on the market.
And very quickly,
I know
that Tim Cook was expected
to talk about Apple's strategy
and what relates to
I did we hear anything as he
spoken about this, but
so far, nothing explicitly.
I although there have been
some updates on autocorrect,
if you've used an iPhone,
you know how difficult that can be.
But, you know, right now
I'm in Silicon Valley.
Virtually every tech company
is focusing on A.I.
Google recently in their annual event,
focused almost entirely A.I..
So a lot of questions
about how Apple will
directly integrate it
into their software.
I'm very quickly.
Yes.
And I do
see this headset taking off trying at all
Well, look,
this is a huge risk for Apple, right?
I mean,
think of what Apple does
with their product.
Usually they wait for a product
to be in the market for a few years
and then come out with their version,
which they hope to be the best.
It's been a very successful strategy.
With earphones,
with AirPods
all the way back to the iPhone, to iPods.
This is a market
that hasn't really been proven yet.
Consumers haven't shown the inclination
for putting a big, expensive thing
on top of their head
and stepping into the virtual reality
of the virtual world.
But, you know, Apple,
they don't have a lot of misses.
So Tim Cook and CO are working
worked hard on this device.
We'll see if consumers line up to get it.
Yeah, I know the others have tried it.
I haven't actually done well.
Let's see if Apple succeeds
where others have failed.
John Sutherland, appreciate it.
Thanks very much.